then the Lord rained upon Sodom and upon
Gomorrah brimstone and fire from the
Lord out of heaven and he overthrew the
cities and all the plain and all the
inhabitants of the cities and that which
grew up on the ground but his wife
looked back from behind him and she
became a pillar of salt no nostalgia for
catastrophe I think that's what that
means is that when you leave what's not
good you wash the dust off your feet and
you don't look back
and that's a very harsh lesson this is
that could a bit in the New Testament
the idea of the necessity for immediate
action these are some of the harsher
words that Christ said this is from
Matthew 8 Christ is addressing a
multitude and asking people to follow
him and a disciple comes up to him and
says Lord suffer me first to go and bury
my father seems like a perfectly
reasonable request but jesus said unto
him follow me and let the dead bury
their dead this is from Matthew 12 well
he had talked to the people behold his
mother and his brethren stood without
desiring to speak with him then one said
to him behold thy mother and my brethren
stand without desiring to speak with
thee but jesus answered the one who was
telling him and said who has my mother
and who is my brothers for whosoever
shall do the will of my father which is
in heaven the same as my brother and
sister and mother well what does all
that mean it means that there's no
excuses whatsoever for not getting up
and getting at it that's what it means
and it means that it even means that
when people are beset with the
catastrophe like let's say the death of
their father that they are prone to use
that as an excuse for not going about
the business that they should be going
about because they can say to themselves
well I would accept and
cept there's always good reasons I mean
believe me there's always good reasons
for not doing what you should that's for
sure the reasons pile up day after day
to not do what you should especially
because you're you're aiming at things
in the future you can put them off and
definitely right because of the demands
of the day but these stories they say a
variety of things you know and
especially in combination they say when
you leave somewhere terrible do not look
back
there's no nostalgia that's that's the
letting the dead parts of yourself go
and then if you're going to follow the
good there's no excuse not to do it and
that and it means no excuse whatsoever
under any circumstances and then it's
taken even farther with regards to
familiar relationships it is you can't
even let them stand in your way and I
think that's all true and I think I've
seen virtually all of that in my
clinical practice like there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at what it is
that you should be doing and I think
there's something else that's going on
here especially in the New Testament
stories which is even maybe worse which
is it's absolutely reprehensible to
justify your in action with the
catastrophe that extracts mercy from
other people right there's a tricky
tricky game that's going well of course
I can't do that look at the terrible
thing that's just happened to me it's
yeah okay I understand you're absolved
of any necessity to move forward because
of your current catastrophe it's like
well actually you're not and it's rather
rude of you to use it as an excuse and
it's certainly counterproductive